i would park at the back of the parking
lot and i would open the trunk and climb
in and pull it shut behind me and crawl
over all my seats to get out that's how
i would come to and fro
sure now meghan markle's ridden in
horse-drawn carriages and who can forget
that cute jaguar convertible from her
wedding day
but way before all that when she was an
up-and-coming actress meg had her fair
share of car trouble
let's talk about this for a second the
40 year old duchess of sussex stopped by
the ellen degeneres show on wednesday
and recalled auditioning for projects on
the same lot where the talk show is
taped i would park at gate 3 and then i
would scoot on over and what was so nice
is the security guards here would always
say break a leg we hope you get it so to
drive in today was
very different
but they you auditioned that often that
they knew you to say i think they
probably said it to everybody that's
nice
not only was the ride onto the lot
different because now she's a royal
after marrying prince harry in 2018 it
was also different because of the car
she arrived in so i had this very very
old ford explorer sport and at a certain
point the
the key stopped working on the driver's
side so you couldn't get yourself in
through the door so after auditions i
would park at the back of the parking
lot and i would open the trunk and climb
in and pull it shut behind me and crawl
over all my seats to get out that's how
i would come to and fro
but megan was slick about it and said no
one ever noticed her special technique i
would play it off i would go like oh i'm
just looking for my resume and my
highlighters from my script oh maybe
it's back there and then crawl
oh my god yeah of course meg's
appearance on ellen marks the mom of
two's first time on a daytime talk show
since becoming a duchess pretty special
and speaking of first appearances queen
elizabeth just reemerged for the first
time amid some ongoing health concerns
over the weekend the 95 year old royal
was forced to miss the remembrance
sunday service after spraining her back
it really would have taken something
quite severe to have stopped her from
being there on the day on wednesday the
queen met with british military's chief
of staff general nicholas carter in
windsor castle's oak room her royal
highness rocked a colorful floral dress
for the occasion as she stood to welcome
nicholas who is preparing to step down
from his role at the end of november
this comes after the queen spent sunday
resting after spraining her back
remembrance sunday is probably the most
important date in the queen's diary it's
inked in at the beginning of the year
and in fact i think she has only missed
commemoration sunday or remembrance
sunday which is essentially to honor the
fallen heroes of world war 1 and world
war ii something very important to her
as head of the armed forces she's only
missed that four times in her reign
twice when she was pregnant with andrew
and edward and twice when she was
overseas so it's a hugely
important occasion for her
in a statement released by buckingham
palace at the time the queen's royal
communications team said she was bummed
to cancel her sunday commitments
a royal source also told et quote it is
obviously incredibly unfortunate timing
and nobody regrets the queen's absence
more deeply than her majesty herself her
majesty is deeply disappointed she
missed the engagement which she regards
as one of the most significant
engagements of the year she hopes to
continue as planned with her schedule of
light official duties
sunday's service was set to be the first
public appearance by the queen since
spending the night in the hospital last
month a buckingham palace spokesperson
told et at the time that the queen was
in the hospital for quote some
preliminary investigations
i think the general public are very
concerned about the queen's health she
is 95 years old and up until now she has
been in robust health i mean i think
it's safe to say that we will probably
see less of the queen in the run-up to
christmas but in terms of how much
information we're getting from the
palace i can tell you the palace is
always very guarded in what it said
about the queen but particularly what it
said about the queen's medical health
condition
according to the spokesperson queen
elizabeth returned to windsor castle the
following day at lunchtime and was said
to be in good spirits
[Music]
you